hi everyone my name is Jake I work on
the Android team on Kotlin stuff and so
today I'm gonna be talking about Android
KTX and I'm not gonna be talking about
I'm not gonna be just going over a bunch
of the stuff that's in there I want to
make it a little more interesting than
that so I'm gonna start with a little
bit of what happened last year at Google
i/o I was here last year talking about
how you can write extensions for Android
types such as this example where we have
code that iterates over the views inside
of a view group you can pull that common
code out into an extension what this
extension does is enhance a type that we
don't control the view group type we're
allowed to essentially create a member
function that's not actually a member
function it actually turns into a static
function in the bytecode with the
functionality that we want to enhance
and so we can take our original code
that had the explicit for loop in it and
use this new member to create a more
concise version of what we intended to
do it is actually visually distinguished
from a normal member function that it's
italicized if you use dark yellow it
will actually be yellow but it's
semantically equivalent to calling a
member or the intent is to feel
semantically equivalent and so
oftentimes when you start talking about
extension functions you think well if
this is so useful why don't we just put
the function directly off do you group
why doesn't view group just offer a for
each and a for each index that takes in
a lambda and really the reason is
because of the lambda when we pass a
lambda in Java e or in Kotlin by default
that has to create an anonymous class
which eats up methods and causes class
loading Kotlin however provides language
functionality which allows us to
eliminate that lambdas allocation by
marking the function is inline the body
of the extension gets copied into the
call site and we have a Z
overhead abstraction let's take a look
at another example an API 23 we were
able to get a system service based on a
class type and in 27.1 of the support
libraries a context compat version of
this was added that allowed it to work
on all API levels we can pull this into
an extension that is also in line like
the previous one but doesn't contain a
lambda what this one has that's
different is something called reified
now this is a compiler trick and what
that trick does is it forces the type
information of the generic to be known
at compile time so that it can be made
available at runtime and so this is what
allows us to take where we would
otherwise be calling you know classic
Java on notification manager we can now
abstract that away behind this extension
and so our calling code now becomes
simplified to just be able to pass the
generic and because it's reified we have
the implementation of that has access to
be able to call class that Java
so if we want to update the padding of a
view just where we're only specifying
two of the four parameters in this case
we want to update both the left and the
right we have to pull out the existing
padding for the top and the bottom
because Android requires you to specify
all four this is something that we can
remedy again using an extension function
the key here is that for each of the
arguments on this new function that
we've defined we're specifying a default
and that default will be used whether
when a value is not provided for that
argument so it allows us to take the
calling code where we're specifying all
four and now specify them as just two
but the problem here is that you know
we've eliminated two of the arguments
but since we're only supplying two
Kotlin takes that as meaning the first
two and this the latter two are the ones
where the defaults are used this is not
what we intended to be intended to do
left and right which are the first and
third another language feature comes to
help here
which is named arguments named
parameters rather by specifying the name
of the parameter were able to tell the
compiler which of the two arguments we
were specifying and allow it to fill in
the defaults for the others
okay Android has Android AP eyes have a
bunch of composite types these are
things like point rectangle pair even
the location class these composite types
are just wrappers around smaller
individual pieces of data in this case
I'm calling an epi which has a rectangle
which is a composite around the for the
left top right and bottom values of a
rectangle and if you need to do
calculations based on the values inside
of these composite types you have to
pull them out into individual values or
variables in order to do that
calculation and then potentially put
them all back together so with the help
of the extension we can avoid this this
one is a little bit different we have a
new keyword called an operator an
operator means that Kotlin will allow us
to use a special call cite syntax and
each operator function has a very
specific name a well-known name you
can't just make up any name and the name
defines which call site syntax that
you're intending to create in this case
it's called component and component
allows us to use a feature of Kotlin
called destructuring and so our original
code which had to individually pull out
the four different components can now
use this call site syntax where the
rectangle has automatically unpacked
into the four values and assigned to
four variables with names that we choose
what's really nice about this is that if
you don't care about ones later on you
can omit them and if you don't care
about ones in the middle you can specify
them as underscore and so if we just
need to pull out two of the values we
can do that very succinctly
okay an experienced cotton user might
know that well I guess we flipped it we
go back a slide okay so this is some
code that shows how we could determine
whether or not a string contains only
digits it basically just loops through
the characters using Cotton's for in
syntax checks whether it's a digit using
an extension function on character and
then sets a value to true or false
whether the text it whenever it detects
an on digit if you're an experienced
countless or you might know about the
all function which exists on string
which encapsulate s-- the same looping
allows you to specify a predicate which
in this case is that is digit it's
actually an inline function so it D
sugars into the exact same thing we
would have wrote in the previous slide
but what's interesting is that Android
actually has a built-in function for
this and I suspect that a lot of people
don't actually know this exists and so
this is something that we can actually
take and turn into an extension but you
start to wonder is this actually worth
its weight in an extension what value do
we gain by turning this static method
that we can call into an extension well
for one it changes the way that we
invoke to feel a lot more natural and
idiomatic and Colin sure but still what
is there really value that we extract
from this the biggest one that I think
we gain from this is that when you're in
the IDE you have your string and you're
wanting to go and determine whether or
not it's you're wanting to make this
query as to whether or not it contains
only digits if you didn't know that
static method on text utils was there
you probably would never find it when
it's extension if you start typing in
the IDE it will actually show this
extension in autocomplete where it's
much more discoverable than otherwise so
you just press ENTER and get it alright
so I've covered a few extent
here I just wanted to remind you a bit
of the power of these extensions the
fact that we are leveraging language
features that exist only in Kotlin not
in the java language and actually some
of these examples were going to keep
coming back to you throughout the rest
of this talk so all the extensions that
I just showed are part of the Android
KTX library that we announced in early
February there's been two releases since
then and as of Tuesday it's now part of
jetpack it's part and version with
jetpack so on Tuesday core KTX is now
100 alpha one it's going to be versioned
and released with future jetpack
libraries so we call this core KTX when
we launched which was kind of a weird
name it didn't make sense this was for
extensions for types only in the
framework a lot of people suggested can
we add support library stuff and we were
very adamant about saying no that should
hopefully make a lot more sense now but
even this isn't exactly true because
core KTX initially depended on support
compat support compat is there to
provide backwards compatibility versions
of things that are in the android
framework and so earlier I showed the
example with context compat that's
something that came from support compat
and so now with the jetpack rebranding
and the Android X packages support
compat has become core and so now core
KTX lines up with core so we kind of
knew what we were doing back when we
started this and now it's only starting
to pay off
along with the other jetpack libraries
there's actually a few new KTX libraries
that are launching with it so we have
ones for a fragment collection sequel
light for the newer components
navigation and work runtime I'm going to
touch on how you can discover these a
bit later but I want to talk a bit about
scoping about how we determine whether
or not
something is something should go into
one of these libraries
alright so in core TTX 0.3 we offered an
extension that looks like this if you
look at its signature
it's an operator and it operates on
color and the name is plus so this
allows us to use the normal plus syntax
for adding for compositing two colors
together so the signature it's
definitely an extension but the body of
this looks very different than the other
extensions we looked at there's a
significant amount of code in here if
you look inside sport compat which is
that core there is a color utilities
class and that color utilities class has
a method called composite colors that
works on integer colors it allows you to
take a foreground in the background and
turn them into a single color so this is
the perfect candidate for placing the
implementation of where that what that
extension function was into this class
so that everyone can use it so that it
can be used from the java language or
the column language and so in core KTX
1.0 this actually has been rewritten to
just delegate to that color utils so the
java language users get that
functionality but the colin users get
the enhanced syntax and if you look at
the extensions that we talked about so
far the bodies of them the
implementation of these functions
they're all trivial they're exceedingly
trivial and that's by design and this
gets me into covering some of the
principles that we want to that we
define that key TX extensions should
have and so this first one is that we
want to adapt functionality that already
exists and if we want to add any new
features there should be redirected
upstream to a place for their language
agnostic where both languages can take
it
each of them other examples of this was
there was some HTML compat stuff and a
path iterator that were implemented
first and Corky TX that have since moved
upstream into core to be able to use
them both languages
another thing that's common to all these
extensions is that they're marked as in
line the reason that we do in line on
the first one the one at the top is that
we want to avoid the lambda allocation
for the second one because we're using
reified generics
we're actually forced to use in line by
the compiler the third the component
ones and the very bottom one are all in
line mostly because they're just aliases
to what you would otherwise write if the
extension didn't exist if we look at an
example of something that's not in line
in core KTX we have this iterator
extension to viewgroup which allows us
to use collins for in syntax to iterate
over the views in a view group this is
not in line for a very specific reason
and that is because it defines the
implementation of this function defines
an anonymous class if we were to inline
this that means that every time you use
it
an anonymous class would be defined at
your call site and so this would
increase your deck size method count and
class loading we explicitly make this
not inline because we want that single
implementation to be reused by all of
the callers so we default to an
extension being inline unless there are
allocation reasons and I should note
that this is really only for KTX style
extensions in normal collin code this is
not a good recommendation you don't want
to default the inline because it has the
potential to lead to actually
having a negative effect on your code
rather than a positive one
all right so earlier when we showed this
extension I talked about how the inline
modifier coupled with the fact that
there's a lambda allows this extension
to be a zero overhead abstraction in the
rio5 case we get a the ability to have a
more declarative version of the lookup
at the call site without having to
specify the colon colon class Java for
updating the padding we get to use
default values to not have to specify
each of the arguments and name
parameters to specify which subset of
arguments we want to actually provide
for the destructuring case we get the
fancy syntax that allows us to pull
apart the component variables out of a
composite object this is useful this is
enabled by the fact that we are we have
operator overloading Kotlin we also
talked about how we were able to add the
plus or color for this one we're a Lea
Singh in extension to a static method
and this is just to help improve
discoverability for built-in helpers
that you might otherwise not know exist
and then for types that are collection
like but not actually collections we
have the ability to turn them into
pseudo collections where we can use the
affordances of the language as if they
were actual collections and so each one
of those has a very Colin specific
language feature that it uses and we
want to make sure that all these
extensions that we're defining leverage
some feature of the common language that
doesn't otherwise exist for Java callers
we want to resist trying to fix an API
just by creating extensions for it but
rather enhance it to become more
pleasant to use by leveraging these
Scotland
specific features okay one of the
suggestions we get quite frequently is
to take something like set
onclicklistener and write an extension
which allows you to call it using
something like click or on click this
allows the calling code to instead of
having to call set onclicklistener we
get the shorter version of click are we
leveraging a feature of the language
here well we're leveraging extension
functions but not really we're really
just creating a shorter alias what value
are we extracting from this extension
well we're typing a few less characters
but really it's all auto-completed
anyway but even worse what precedent
will we be setting here by by adding
this extension are we gonna do this for
every listener and so this is a great
example of something we explicitly do
not want to do in the KTX libraries if
you're not familiar with the term we
call this code golf where you have a
desire to create the shortest code
possible this is something we do not
want to do we're not here to just make
the code shorter okay there's another
one that gets suggested every now and
then and that I've seen people using
with Android because of the different
API levels we have to support you very
frequently see these if checks around
that the SDK it so can be tempting to
pull this out into an extension where
you have a little bit more declarative
version of this we move the comparison
into an extension function it's an
inline function so we don't have the
overhead the lambdas the last parameter
so you get the nice Kotlin call site
syntax and it turns our if statement
from this into this now this by itself
is is not too terrible we're really not
leveraging any of the language features
again similar to the last one we're it's
still kind of an alias but at least this
one you can argue a little bit more for
its merits but there's a problem while
these two statements are equivalent what
happens when well for one thing is that
you can at least static import SDK in
and then they're a little bit closer
that's one reason why this is less
justified but one thing is that an if
statement is a very primitive construct
of a programming language and because an
if statement is not just an if statement
there's constructs like else so what if
your requirements change such that you
need to alter the behavior on these two
different versions well if you were
using this extension that you wrote in
order to support this case you either
have to change back to using an if
statement or you have to modify the
function where maybe it takes two
lambdas now one for the case where
you're above 19 one for the case where
you're not because we're now taking two
lambdas in this function we've lost the
special trailing lambda syntax where we
we now have to pass them as arguments
inside the parentheses whereas before we
did so immediately this extension starts
falling apart if we introduce another
conditional branch maybe we need to vary
the behavior across api's in three
different ways
well there's really no way that we can
make the extension do this the other
thing that is different about this
extension compared to the if statement
is that we're assuming the conditional
that we want to check is greater than or
equal to that the behavior we want to
run in the lambda we only want to run on
you know nineteen plus well a lot of
times some of the if statements again
sdk int will be less than or equal to
and so now we need a second extension in
order to support that use case so this
is another example of something that
we're not looking to do we don't want to
optimize for just a single use case or a
specific use case where
extension only supports one way of doing
something and then when you need to move
to something more complex you have to
revert to the original behavior we want
the extensions to you allow you to
express everything you would need to
express if it didn't exist okay so those
all the extensions we've been talking
about thus far have been ones that are
in the core KTX library I don't want to
go through a ton of the extensions that
are in these other libraries again I'm
going to show you how you can discover
them in a bit but I want to touch on
touch on one so for the fragment KTX we
have an extension which encapsulate s--
transactions we move the begin
transaction and the commit function
calls into an extension we use the fact
that we can use an inline function and a
lambda again to turn this into a zero
overhead thing our calling code then
becomes a little bit shorter where we
now use the transaction with a lambda
body so if you've used fragments you'll
know that commit is not the only
commitment function there's actually
more than one and so we can model this
by doing something like allowing you to
supply a boolean as to whether or not
you want to allow state loss or disallow
state loss when you're committing this
is really easy to accommodate but it
sort of goes against something I said
earlier where and we can update our call
site to be able to use this it sort of
goes against something I said earlier
though where I talked about minimizing
the impact of the implementation of
these extensions since this is an inline
function and then we've now put a
conditional inside that inline function
but conditional is being inlined
into all the call sites and so all the
call sites now have to have
additional inside of them so is this
actually a bad thing well if we look at
the bytecode that gets generated from
the call site when we specify allow
state loss true you don't really have to
understand byte code to understand
what's going on here there's essentially
three function calls
the first one is begin transaction the
second one is that replace which was
inside the lambda and the third one is
just a call to commit allowing stay loss
there's no if statement here
there's no conditional and that's
because since this is an inline function
and since the argument is a boolean the
compiler actually knows at compile time
what value you're supplying and so since
it knows a compile time it can actually
do dead code elimination and eliminate
the branches that can never possibly be
executed and so you actually get in
bytecode what's equivalent to what you
otherwise whatever written there's
actually more commit functions there's
one which allow you to commit now and
commit so we can also support that by
adding an additional boolean the same
thing happens here even though they are
now nested dead code elimination will
make it so that there is only one
function call in the resulting bytecode
okay as part of the this effort of all
these releases at i/o one of the things
that we've done is start creating a
Collins specific view of the libraries
that we publish and the android
framework itself so if you see in that
blue box there when you visit the
reference reference Docs it'll actually
show you that it I don't ask you if you
want to view a Collins specific version
of the platform or Android X libraries
and also if you scroll down and that
left navigation pane at the very bottom
we have links to them as well and what
these are are
a Colin view of these libraries and so
when you're browsing through say the
fragment package you'll be able to see
the extensions for fragment inside the
documentation it's no longer completely
separate one thing that's missing right
now is that we we don't actually tell
you the Maven coordinates of the the
artifact that these come from that's
coming soon and also the extensions in
core KTX
which extends the platform types don't
yet show up on the platform Doc's but
this is something that we wanted to get
out to show you that it's being worked
on and so hopefully those two things
will be coming soon all right I want to
touch on you know I'm here to talk about
Android KTX but callin extensions
there's nothing Android specific about
it what we're doing is building
extensions to try and make these
libraries more Kotlin friendly and
that's something that any library can do
and so I want to talk about the ways
that we think about how we can make
libraries more Kotlin friendly that
applied to both the Android libraries
but also applied to libraries that you
might be writing or you might be using
the first way to make a library really
column friendly is just rewrite the
whole thing in Kotlin I mean obviously
this isn't feasible for every library
but it's certainly an option for some if
it's a library that's private to your
app it's in your repository or its
internal to your company and you're
already using Kotlin this is a viable
option doesn't seem like something
that's totally viable for say the
android framework and I'm not quite sure
we're at the stage where an Android X
library could do this maybe a future
Android X library could be written in
Kotlin that seems like a strong
possibility what we've chosen to do with
most of the things that we publish is
sibling artifacts so the the main
library remains written
using Java language and we ship Kotlin
language features as a sibling artifacts
what's great about this is you don't
force the Kotlin standard library onto
your consumers unless they explicitly
want it you can curate the extensions to
be exactly what's needed to augment your
API where you get the Kotlin specific
features and what's really nice about
this is you don't have to control the
library that you're extending so if
you're just consuming a library and you
want to make part of it more column
friendly you can do that you can do that
either in your own app or you can
publish a set of extensions for a
library that someone else publishes but
is this the only are these the only two
options I want to take a look at
something that I think will lead into a
third somewhat hybrid option and I go
back to this simple alias extension
where we've taken the static method
defined in the Java language and turned
it into an extension method in the
Kotlin language if we look at the
implementation of this class on the Java
side I've included the first line
because we can see that it immediately
dereferences the argument that we pass
in as soon as we pass in a string it
says what's the you know maximum number
of characters that I can iterate over in
order to determine whether or not there
are digits and so if you've been using
Kotlin with java api x' you might know
that this means that the parameter is
going to be exposed as what's called a
platform type it has unknown null
ability but by from the implementation
we know right away that this method
simply cannot extend cannot accept null
values in the way that we would fix this
is by adding the non null annotation so
that what this annotation does is it
informs the collin compiler that there's
a restriction that there's special
behavior that it needs to take into
account where it needs to
in force that no one passes a
potentially nullable value or null into
this method and so this is something
this is all this is enabling a language
feature in Kotlin that simply doesn't
exist in Java now you can use tools that
will allow this enforcement to work for
a job but it's not intrinsic to the
language itself so if we can do
something like that for null Ness if we
can add this annotation for nullus to
inform the Kotlin compiler that it needs
to change its behavior when we invoke
this method can we do this for something
else say I want to take this static
method where the first argument is
really the the receiver and can I say
that this is actually going to be an
extension function when can vote from
Kotla and what this allows us to do
potentially is eliminate the need to
have this explicitly defined extension
at all right this extension only exists
you change the calling convention to
inform the compiler that we want to
allow you to call it in a different way
and so now we're left with just this the
Kotlin compiler sees that annotation
just like it's all the non null
annotation infer something from it and
allows you to call it in a way that's
more idiomatic for that language in the
bytecode we get what we otherwise would
have written right we still get the the
call to the static method and the
receiver becomes the first argument how
about this example
one thing you might have noticed is that
this extension is named update padding
not set padding now we can actually call
this extension set padding but the
problem is that it will only work for a
subset of arguments so in this case
we're we're just passing left and right
values we could call that set padding
and it would work fine but if we passed
left right and then top bottom
we'd be supplying four arguments and the
Kotlin compiler is going to see that the
real set padding also accepts four
arguments and it's going to prefer
calling the real one and the real one
doesn't have named parameters so you're
gonna get a compilation error that's the
reason we have to name this update
padding if we look at the real set
padding simple method that takes four
integers what if we could inform the
Kotlin compiler that these parameters
have names associated with them now it
would be nice to infer this just from
the parameter names directly not have to
specify the redundancy but I'll argue
that for one it's very nice being
explicit about these names in the
annotation in Java bytecode there
actually is a way for you to supply to
retain parameter names so the common
compiler could in theory use those but
one problem is that then it becomes an
all-or-nothing thing you have to in you
have to opt in to this behavior and then
suddenly every parameter name across
your library is set in stone whereas
with annotations that's something that
you could incrementally migrate so this
solves the this has the potential to
solve the naming part where now we can
call the real method from Colin and
specify the four arguments in any order
that we want based on what names we
provide how about the default value what
if we could pass in what if we could
specify an expression a Colin expression
which allowed the compiler to supply a
default when one wasn't supplied for you
by you
this would change our original extension
calling convention from calling our
extension to actually just using the
real method and then in the bytecode we
get the thing that we've started with
the thing that our explicit extension
would in line too but now the extension
doesn't have to exist the metadata that
we added in the form of annotations
informed the Colin compiler that we
wanted to enhance our ability to call
this function in a call and specific way
leveraging the Kotlin features and so
we're able to do so this is something so
colin has this process which is called
keep its collin evolution and
enhancement process and just this
morning we proposed this these
extensions or sorry these annotations as
keep 1:10 so this is something we're
proposing to add to the Colin compiler
so that it can understand these
annotations we have extension function
and extension property which are for
static methods default value which
allows supplying default values for
parameters and then Katie name which
allows you to provide an alternate name
for methods fields or parameters now
it's very important to note that this is
this is extremely early these names
might change the semantics might change
this may never actually be accepted into
the Colin compiler we have been working
with the JetBrains team for quite a
while on this and it's actually already
some of this is already prototyped
inside the Colin compiler we really
think this would be a way that we could
enhance the android framework for Kotlin
callers without actually having to go
and rewrite the android framework or at
least its API and Kotlin which is really
not feasible and it's also important to
note that while this is an option
assuming that it actually makes it into
the Colin compiler
it doesn't totally solve every problem
that our existing extensions are are
solving where we determine these
annotations that we proposed and keep
110 through looking through a bunch of
open source libraries looking through
our own libraries and seeing what we
thought would be the most useful
extensions what the the pattern of Java
methods were such that they would want
to be turned into extensions and so the
latter two really are complementary the
big advantages of the annotations is
that you you retain the single source of
truth you don't have to really know
Kotlin you don't have to add Kotlin
compiler to your build system you don't
have to publish tippling artifacts even
if you're a pure Java library you can
add these annotations and just enhance
your API so that Kotlin callers get the
more idiomatic syntax all right so to
sum up core KTX
is now part of android jetpack version
with android jetpack released with
Android jetpack there's a few new
artifacts as you can see here on the
screen there's definitely more coming
notable ones that we think are missing
our slices and view model so I would not
be surprised to see artifacts for those
in the coming months please check out
the Kotlin version of the reference
document or yeah the reference we you
know this is this is extremely early
where this required changes in daca and
and how we produce Docs and so it's
something we just wanted to get out
there and show you as a preview this is
definitely something that's being
actively worked on there's a new
component on the Android bug tracker for
Android KTX because core KTX and all the
KTX libraries are now part of jetpack
the source of truth has moved into the
support repository we're gonna be
migrating get the github issues on the
github project over to this bug tracker
in the coming weeks but it's important
to note that we're still going to be
accepting poor requests to the github
repo and syncing things back out to the
github repo it's just that the issues
will no longer be the source of truth on
github it will be on the Android bug
tracker
they keep was proposed I created the
poor request about an hour ago please go
check that out the the document contains
a lot more detail about examples like I
said the annotations that were chosen
are the ones that we think have the most
impact but at the bottom of the document
you'll see that there's if something
like this gets accepted there's a
potential for a future enhancement of
even more the the link to that should be
this I made this link last night before
I submitted it so hopefully it's
accurate and that's it thank you
[Music]